genau 500 jahre ist es her seit hier in
basel
das neue testament zum ersten mal in
dieser griechisch lateinischen ausgabe
erschienen geschaffen hat diese
übersetzung der humanist erasmus von
rotterdam pausen feiert dieses ereignis
unter anderem mit einer ausstellung hier
im historischen museum wo ich sie
herzlich begrüße
doch wer war dieser eröffnungs warum
wird dieses buch heute noch ausbauen
brechen das ereignis bezeichnet und was
ist vom humanismus geblieben
diesen fragen gehe ich heute nach in
einem stadtrundgang durch basel und im
gespräch mit dem philosophen adriano
mannino der den humanismus evolutionär
weiterdenken
zuerst aber spreche ich mit rudolf er
ist theologe und philosoph und er kennt
sich bestens aus mit der epoche des
humanismus
herzlich willkommen in europa 500 jahre
das ist eine lange zeit was hat uns
erasmus denn heute noch zu sagen
also erstens wenn ich die bemerkung von
ansteckender 500 jahre sind nicht so
viel wie man denken könnte
1517 feiern wir die den thesenanschlag
500 jahre reformation sozial besser dass
das innovations- ereignis und
machiavelli war dran 1513 mit dem 500
jährigen jubiläum das der verfassung des
prinzips also man sieht 500 jahre nimmt
man eigentlich mit leichtem fuß und bei
erasmus erkläre ich mir das so er hatte
nicht wie machiavelli sein materialismus
als brücke er hatte nicht viel luther
eine eigene kirche als brücke zur
gegenwart was hatte er hatte die
sensation des ketzerischen freien autors
das tridentinische konzil vorträge oder
integrieren könnte einen fehler gemacht
haben als es seine schriften auf den
index setzte sowas macht neugierig und
diese neugier kann nachhaltig wirken das
hat mir bei ihm der fall zu sein ähnlich
wie bei giordano bruno das ist gerade
schon ein gutes stichwort für das lob
der torheit eine der ganz berühmten
schriften von erasmus von rotterdam zu
seinen lebzeiten in 36 auflagen
veröffentlicht
in diesem buch macht erasmus von
rotterdam ja eigentlich so etwas wovon
ich gedacht habe das ist fast ein
bisschen wie böhmermann heute führt
nämlich die un- eigentliche rede einer
lässt eine thülen auftreten
die über alles her zieht was die kurie
und das papsttum für gut befinden und
machte ich unglaublich lustig darüber
dass ein ich zur zeit der inquisition
ganz schön mutig gewesen das ist
unerhört ein gewisser hinsicht sogar
auch als typus als als genre
dieses buch hat mindestens einen
doppelten boden wenn mich schreibt
jemand ein lob der torheit von dem man
nicht weiß welche position er selber
gegenüber der torheit einnimmt wenn er
die hoheit lobt ist es selbst ein
ausdruck einer gewissen frei gewählten
torheit wir vorher zu loben oder ist es
ein töpfern weisheit der sich wiederum
aber von der weisheit der unterscheiden
muss gehen nur die der die torheit
privilegiert wird und diese diese frage
kann man nicht eindeutig beantworten
und warum kommt der sich das
herausnehmen eben ich glaube die
inquisition noch man muss auch sagen
hier raus und es war ja selber
katholischer priester hat er offenbar
keine angst
er war sehr mutig auf als eine art und
weise und das ist wichtig diese diese
eigenschaft von ihnen zu unterstreichen
weil ihm gerne besonders in der
geschichte der theologischen rezeption
vorgeworfen wird er sei doch ein
bisschen zurückhaltend ein bisschen
zaghaft gewesen was den was sein
engagement für die reformation anbetraf
das war aber keine keine zurückhaltung
in dem sinne dass er zauberte dass er
nicht mutig gewesen wäre einzugreifen
sondern das war es ein wieder bilden
gegen die reformation
er war mutig genug sich mit beiden
fronten anzulegen mit den reformatoren
einfacher matte mutter lauf kommen wir
vielleicht noch und mit meter
katholischen kirche als er war ein
mutiges individuum und er hatte es
gewagt seiner literarischen kompetenz
einfach ausdruck zu verleihen da ist was
in den durchgebrochenen mutig war ja ein
stück weit eben auch diese
bibelübersetzung erbringt diesen
griechischen rotex und einer
lateinischen neuen übersetzung und falle
mit einem ganzen anhang die sämtliche
übersetzungsfehler die er so ausgemacht
hatte versammelt und das war
wahrscheinlich ein stück weit
schon wissen eine ohrfeige auch für die
kurie die die wohl gartner verbreitete
die damalige lateinische übersetzung die
hat er ja mit aufgenommen wenn schnell
sagen darf er hatte er den griechischen
text um die wulka sozusagen zur optisch
präsentiert miteinander mit der man aber
trotzdem diese vielen übersetzungsfehler
daneben ausgewiesen
das hat wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt
nicht so sehr die fans und gar nicht
damit hat eine gewisse autonomie
bewiesen eine gewisse souveränität
gegenüber traditionen bewiesen die
gewissermaßen dem ideal des
humanistischen gelehrten entsprach und
wenn man so will da erkennt man
mindestens so sehr wenn nicht sogar mehr
den humanisten in ihm dass die
philologische genauigkeit die treue zum
zur quelle der maßstab war auch
gegenüber doktrinärer dogmatischer
ideologischer oder was weiß ich wie
immer geleiteter tradition
er stand damit im besten der besten
tradition der italienischen humanisten
die allesamt aus ihrer philologie und
ihrer physiologischen kompetenz eine
unbestechliche tugend gemacht haben seit
dem 14 jahrhundert fahrers eine kultur
geworden und das zeichnet auch die
geschichte und integrierte geschichte
des humanismus
was ist denn so brisant daran eine neue
bibel übersetzung vorzulegen oder diesen
griechischen urtext vorzulegen das
brisante ist daran dass man eine gewisse
ein gewisses implizites misstrauen
gegenüber den traditionellen formen
damit zum ausdruck bringt das heißt sie
haben das eben selber schon angedeutet
dieser frage erasmus spielt praktisch
die quelle aus gegen ihre kirchliche
rezeptionsgeschichte und diese
konfrontation ist gewollt und bewusst
warum tut er das nicht weil er streits
wichtig wäre nicht nur misstrauen hätte
nein weil er findet dass es die quelle
verdient hat und dass es höchste zeit
führt nicht verdeckt zu werden von ihrer
eigenen rezeptions form und die dürfe
sich nicht verselbständigen
das ist auch uhr humanistisch und hängt
mit der neugier zusammen neugier auf das
was wirklich war
was wirklich diese große große liebe zu
den alten sprachen und wenn wir heute
von dem humanistischen bildungsideal
sprechen dann meinen wir damit ein stück
weit eben auch diese auseinandersetzung
vergangenheit in unserer geschichte aber
auch mit der politik mit der literatur
der kunst dieses humanistische bildung
sieht das heute aus spielt gegenüber der
steuerung der sogenannten mint fächer
also naturwissenschaftliche fächer
hätten sich daher rasmus im grab
umgedreht
er hätte sich bestimmt im grab umgedreht
und er wäre an einer unserer wichtigsten
vorkämpfer gewesen und mit unserem einig
uns im bündnis der
geisteswissenschaftler sich dagegen
wehren weil er argumente gehabt hätte
die darüber hinausgehen was man in der
schule so als als zerrbild des
humanismus oft verbreitet gefunden hat
nämlich latein pauken griechischen
vokabeln pauken alte sprachen als
selbstzweck nein alte sprachen sind
wenig selbstzweck alte sprachen sind
lebendige träger von unentbehrlichen
wissen gewesen
das heißt er hatte griechische um 15
herum 1500 herum finger an riesig zu
lernen aus einem spontanen bedürfnis
heraus die quelle auch wirklich zu
verstehen auch da stand der in bester
tradition
mir hat einmal ein kollege in frankreich
gesagt wenn du verstehen willst was die
renaissance denn eigentlich war und
warum es den humanismus als die dieses
haus integrierende bewegung gegeben hat
dann musst du eine frage beantworten
warum der erste unter den großen der
sogenannte vater des humanismus betrag
altgriechisch lernte wenn man weiß warum
er gelesen hat was wollte er wissen dann
wissen wir was die journalismus kam das
finde ich eine schlüsselfrage und die
hat erasmus für die nordalpen humanismus
noch einmal anhand der beetle der bibel
aktualisiert erhoffen sagt er noch an
einer stelle der menschen geht nicht
geboren er wird gebildet also das
bildungsideal ist ihm extrem wichtig ist
denn die idee dieses bildungsideal ist
dass wir alle ein stück weit schon diese
anlagen in uns haben müssen die bloße
entdecken und fördern oder braucht es da
eine ganz spezifische umgebung um dieses
wissen dass wir haben aus uns heraus zu
locker es braucht eine umgebung es
braucht ein teller es braucht eine
gewisse bildungsarbeit enz
wie ich das in kleinen ländern in europa
immer noch mehr finden als den großen
lernen land bildungsarbeit enz für
kleine länder ist deswegen typisch weil
die kleinen sich gegen die großen
behaupten müssen und sie glauben zu
recht dass sie das mit guter bildung tun
ist ein beispiel für so ein kleines land
ja wir sitzen vielleicht gerade in einem
solchen und da habe ich das selber als
dozent ganz intensiv erfahren haben die
zeit in luzern verlangen dass heute in
luzern und bildungshunger der schweizer
hat mir imponiert und der sinn der das
in die hörsäle gedrungen und das ist
eine schöne erfahrung möchte ich nicht
missen ist etwas ganz besonderes
ich weiß dass auch von dänemark also
scheint etwas etwas markantes für solche
kleinen länder zu sein
bildungshunger man muss wissen dass
unter bildung damals verstanden wurde
jemanden zudem zu befördern was in
seinen anlagen steckt das ist eigentlich
die ganz platonische ideen hat er sei
auch wieder mit alten idealen zu tun
erziehen ist nicht züchten erziehen ist
nicht vorm nach einem externen bild das
zu den erzogenen gar nicht passt das
eben auf ort wird ziehen heißt wecken
erziehen heißt entfalten lassen und
erziehen heißt vor allem eine methode zu
applizieren gehe es dem einzelnen
erlaubt sich selbst zu erziehen
erziehung zur selbsterziehung das ist
ein ideal das die journalisten schon bei
den griechen fanden zurechtgefunden
haben
das ist allerdings auch in der
geschichte der rezeption zu man das ein
bisschen verzerrt worden
geben sie mir gleich ein gutes stichwort
weil ich jetzt gerade sagen wollte wenn
sie sagen sich selbst erziehen das
klingt also ein bisschen soeben aus
hätten wir die anlagen in uns aber
bereits heute gibt es diese ist ideal
dass er nach außen weist und michael
succow hab das ja kritisiert da gesagt
der humanist der wollte eigentlich den
menschen disziplinieren und habe damit
eigentlich das menschliche den menschen
abtrainiert
wenn sie jetzt sagen eigentlich sich
selber erziehen dann klingt das wiederum
gar nicht so sehr nach disziplinierung
ich würde da sie bei aller verehrung für
focus für seine große leistung was die
repressive wirkung der sogenannten
disziplinar macht war daher spricht am
betrifft würde ich sagen die umgestalten
des des vor neuzeitlich journalismus
muss man dagegen verteidigen
und ich glaube foucault braucht sie hat
seine bündnispartner
sie haben das nicht so verstanden aber
er hat recht es ist so geworden
in seinen studien vor allem 17 bis 18
jahrhundert institutionen vergleich
zwischen gefängnissen krankenhäusern
schulen kommt er heraus dass dort eine
disziplin war itc de leitend ist die die
ganze gesellschaft organisiert auch das
ist ganz und gar nicht die idee des
humanisten das so hat die neige nicht
verträgt foto hat zu spät angefangen die
geschichte des humanismus anzusetzen
1304 bitter geburt von petra k ansetzen
sollen und sie haben jetzt schon zweimal
diesen italienischen dichter erwähnt ist
die trucker so etwas wie der vater des
kommunismus man nennt ihn so und ich
habe noch kein argument gefunden dass
dagegen spricht
es ist eine sind ja immer so
nomenklaturen e mail über die man
schreiben kann aber es passt zu ihm
er hat eine art durchbruch erzeugt und
das hat er damit getan dass er den
begriff der so genannten finsternis
eingeführt hat aber er hat nichts von
der finsternis gesprochen als ein
prädikat einer epoche dr hinter sich
hätte auf die man sagt wir etwas
überwunden ist was die die traurige
vergangenheit denn sei sondern als eine
gegenwart an natürlicher petracca hat
über seine zeit gesprochen und seine
finsteren zeit aus der er selber heraus
wollte und heute sagen wir in dem er das
tat hat eine solche distanz zu seiner
eigenen gegenwart markiert das er
gewissermassen mit einem bein draußen
waren interessiert man sich natürlich
aber das interessiert mich jetzt herr
rudolph sie sagen ja es eigentlich der
vater des kommunismus gleichzeitig auch
renaissance und mit renaissance main
jedoch so was wie das mich dass aus dem
dunklen mittelalter wieder aufflackert
warum meine zeit der finsternis für ihn
das licht von dem sie sprechen
flackert für den humanistischen
renaissance gelehrten nicht aus dem so
genannten mittel heraus sondern das muss
man durch das mittelalter hindurch
wieder freilegen
stellen sie sich das vor wie ein dunklen
tunnel durch den mann noch einmal zurück
fliegt um zu finden dass dort am ende
auf der anderen seite ein licht war dass
wir nun nach vorne holen will zu tragen
und das strahlt in der antike und mit
dieser artikel hält es sich zum
sogenannten mittelalter eigentlich ganz
analog wie mit den quellen des neuen
testaments zu seiner so zu sein doch
magischen rezeptions farben mit jungs
sagen er ist durch seine bestimmten die
form bestimmen den übersetzung sprich
mir wieder über erasmus dieser erasmus
dieser public intellectuals der kommt
irgendwann hier in basel
er kommt von rotterdam erfährt also
rheinaufwärts unterwegs begrüßt man ihn
mit dem titel sonne germaniens war
erasmus in seiner zeit so was im kopf
das ist eine frage auf die ich ganz
gerne mit ja antworte wenn man die sache
nur die attraktivität seines auftrittes
betrifft dabei der mann im auge hat wenn
man sie in inhalt meint dann würde ich
noch sagen er hat vielleicht noch mehr
geleistet als ein popstar heute leisten
kann
ein paar popstar heute konkurriert mit
seinen anderen berufskollegen so stark
dass in dem der andere aufgetreten ist
gefahr läuft schon vergessen zu werden
also die berühmtheit von erasmus die
attraktivität von der swisstech glanz
seiner person beruhte darauf dass man
ihm irgendwann merkte er schafft bleiben
das und das hat er ja auch geschafft er
hat früh bewiesen dass er sensation
stiften kann lob der torheit ist eine
sensation
und zwar gerade auch vom unverfrorenen
und provokanten saison eine sensation
das analoge geht für die die bibel
präsentation und das analoge gilt auch
für schriften die innerhalb der eu
zirkulierten und nicht so populär
geworden sind wie zum beispiel seinen
cicero ja nicht dialog den ich
persönlich für sein schönstes buch heißt
also in dieser hinsicht ist ja jemand
gewesen von dem man sofort merkte der
mann ist eine sensation nicht nur weil
er wie ein popstar auftreten kann auf
der bühne eine unmittelbare
massenhypnose entwickeln könnte sondern
weil er strukturen der geschichte der
gesichts vernehmung und vielleicht auch
das geschichts verlauf für die zukunft
verändern kann und er hat sich ja auch
ganz unglaublich angelegt mit martin
luther grunde genommen war er derjenige
der sich so richtig in die haare
gekriegt hat die beiden haben sich
öffentlich inschriften gegenseitig
angegriffen und es ging im zentrum und
im begriff der freiheit sowohl luther
wie erasmus verteidigen ja ein stück
weit die freiheit aber sie verstehen die
freiheit ganz anders und erasmus glaube
ich denkt sich den menschen irgendwie
frage hat man das einfach verstehen
worum es genau ging ich glaube ja
erasmus gehört zu einer heute klar
erkennbaren entwicklungsgeschichte des
humanismus in europa seit betrag die an
einem freiheitsbegriff glaubten von dem
sie nicht nur einfach meinten dass er
ihre idee und ihrer anthropologie ihrer
auffassung von menschen entsprach
sondern von dem sie zugleich meinen das
muss der wille gottes gewesen sein wenn
er den menschen schuf als jemanden der
nicht einfach passiv seine gnade dankbar
entgegen nimmt sondern der zu einer
aktivität einer bestimmten sagen wir mal
spontanität eben zu einem handeln
autonom geeignet ist also gott denkt uns
verantwortlich gar denkt uns
verantwortlich und daran nicht unsere
eben wirklichkeit
es gab den großen pick miranda der in
seinem
in seiner berühmten rede über die würde
des menschen gott zu sprechen ist dass
er ihm gewissermaßen die fähigkeit
vermittelt und das sei seine
besonderheit gegenüber allen anderen
wesen die er noch ist offen habe dass er
die fähigkeit habe sich selber sein
leben heißt das zu gestalten wie ein
bildhauer ein kunstwerk das heißt dass
der die freiheit darin besteht sein
leben als ein kunstwerk autonom zu
gestalten
das war erasmus idee ganz genauso
luther hat in der schrift von erasmus in
terrorismus nicht nur sagt dass das so
sei sondern den der erasmus versucht zu
beweisen dass das biblisch sei dass gott
es gern sich anders gemeint haben könnte
das war etwas das luther besonders auf
die palme gebracht hatte dass der nicht
nur so dachte wie die anderen messen
sondern dass er fand das ist die
ursprüngliche idee des textes den dazu
verdient hat eben wieder philologisch
baby wieder wieder für logisch dass
luther sozusagen durchgebrannt und hat
eine der polemischen schrift wenn man
diesen superlativ gebrauchen kann
verfasst überhaupt und er konnte er
einiges vom leder lassen die er
überhaupt verfasst hat diese schrift ist
insofern eine art von sensation
ihrerseits man muss auch sagen dass die
das ist lothar gelungen war ein reicher
zu verfassen
wie denkt sich denn luther den menschen
nicht der komplett unfrei luther hatte
bis zur schrift von von von erasmus doch
irgendwie sich versucht mit der mit der
demut zu der der mensch verurteilt ist
gegenüber der gnade gottes und ihrer
großzügigkeit einerseits und einem
gewissen freiheit spielraum sich zu
dieser demo zu verhalten andererseits zu
arrangieren und
man kann salär asmus hat ihn dazu
provoziert diese latente balance und
diesen kompromiss mit sich selber ganz
aufzugeben zu sagen jeder akt der
freiheit jede annahme eines potenziell
von potentials und freiheit ist wieder
göttlich ist ein potenzial das dem
freiheitsanspruch gottes seinerseits aus
seiner frau gerade heraus und zu erlösen
eine art von einschränkung bedeutet dass
familien und irgendwie interessant wenn
man sich das vor augen führt man hat ja
immer so das bild eigentlich hat die
reformation den menschen aus um
freiheiten befreit es gab die
inquisition es gab den ablasshandel
diese ganze hierarchischen struktur in
den papst um und da kommt einer wie
luther man hatte den eindruck dass es
doch befreien und jetzt kommen sie uns
sagen nein luther hat eigentlich den
menschen überhaupt nicht frei gedacht
nein fand das also luther hatte ja die
unterscheidung nicht die wir heute schon
haben zwischen dem sagen wir mal
inquisitorischen zug der kirche
einerseits und dem humanismus auf der
anderen seite diese beiden dinge
gehörten als das was man bekämpfen
musste für ihn zusammen das
inquisitorische war das dogmatische
gegen das er als anhänger der schrift
sola scriptura durchsetzte oder
durchzusetzen versuchte was er
allerdings seinerseits also die absolut
setzung der schrift dogmatisch doktrinär
festgelegt hat insofern halten derzeit
automatische haltung schon einmal
aufeinander und die andere seite ist
vielleicht noch viel wichtiger die
humanisten also die erkannte wer noch
nicht unter diesem namen kannte aber die
identifiziert hat mit einem stuhl sind
der es kaum nachzuahmen waren die
dekadente seite der
entwicklungsgeschichte des christentums
den ähren sozusagen rand formen
gegenüber der kirche und diese dekadenz
war für ihn genauso gefährlich wie der
arrogante absolutheitsanspruch eines
inquisitorischen hierhin thoms beides
hat er mit den gleichen waffen bekämpft
und dabei hat er das kind mit dem bade
ausgeschüttet
denn die journalisten waren auf dem
besten wege ihrerseits sozusagen
friedlich und nicht so aggressiv und
fundamentalistische luther subversiv zu
tts wollte ja auch eine form von
reformation alleine ohne tote zone tote
war der absolute pazifist und diese
bedrohliche fundamentalist aggressive
form mit der luther ihm begegnete war
nicht nur fremd fand er nicht nur
politisch falsch sie beim widerlich
jetzt gibt es ja verschiedene formen den
humanismus weiter zu denken es gibt
verschiedene sagen wir mal bewegungen
und strömungen die sich auf den
humanismus beziehen
keine diskussion die im moment die
philosophie beschäftigt die debatte um
den sogenannten traums humanismus also
die vorstellung oder die die sehnsucht
auch den menschen weiter zu entwickeln
und sich zu fragen ob der mensch nicht
mit hilfe von technik von chips im
gehirn von möglichkeiten auch genetische
verbesserungen zu noch besseren menschen
werden könnte was haben sie davon
ich bin mindestens sehr skeptisch
gegenüber dieser sowohl programmatisch
als auch diese begrifflichkeit trans
humanismus eingestellt mindestens
skeptisch aus mehreren gründen einer der
gründe ist wenn man trans mannis muss
sagt will man da nicht eigentlich
andeuten dass man den humanismus auch
überwinden möchte dann sollte man das
auch sagen und dann sollte man ein neues
wort finden
man ist auf dem wege an die humanistisch
zu agieren indem man nicht so wie
erasmus und andere angesetzt haben
mit dem mittel von internen menschlichen
möglichkeiten einer zu einer entfaltung
des individuums beizutragen das ist die
idee des humanismus immer das individuum
sondern wir mal will mit der technik ein
neues wesen schaffen und findet dass man
das auch im auftrag des humanismus
leisten kann weil die technischen
technologischen möglichkeiten ja auch
eine entfaltung dimension eröffnen
würden die wer weiß wohin führt für
entfaltung heißt für sie immer in den im
rahmen dessen zu bleiben auf den
menschen natürlicherweise vorgegeben
also wenn ich ein talent habe klavier zu
spielen dann hat entfaltet und
eigentlich dieses talente aus zu ihm und
nicht aber fördern zu lassen
aber wenn ich meine gesamten tätigkeiten
durch eine art von technik ersetzen
lassen soll
und darauf läuft es hinaus dass die
technik zum zum riesigen hilfsschiffs
roboter wird dann würde ich sagen hat
man eine ganz neue idee die hat mit
humanismus nichts zu tun wenn man das
verkaufen will indem man transformers
muss sagt noch als eine form von
humanismus dann erhalte ich das für
etikettenschwindel reiner
etikettenschwindel wenn man zugibt und
sagt der humanismus ist für mich einer
für uns eine alte kamelle
wir fordern eine neue technologisierung
des menschlichen subjekts bis hin zu
posieren
dann soll man das sagen und da
herbergers feindbild jemand der das ganz
anders sieht ist der philosoph adriano
man ihn mit ihm spreche ich gleich
nachher aber erstmal bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich bei ihnen herr rudolph
dass sie hier waren dankeschön
bevor ich den jungen philosophen adriano
mannino treffen und mit ihm über die
weiterentwicklung des humanismus
sprechen möchte ich verstehen warum er
sich ausgerechnet hier in basel
niederließ warum ging er nicht nach park
münchen oder köln die wichtigsten städte
jener zeit das trage ich jetzt thomas
hofmeier der mich mitnimmt auf einen
stadtrundgang
[Musik]
wir stehen hier im innenhof des
historischen museums es regnet in
strömen
da drüben wurde vor 500 jahren also
erfassungs bibel gedruckt thomas hofmann
ja wie muss man sich eine druckerei in
dieser zeit vorstellen
wahnsinnig laut dreckig eine mischung
zwischen einer waschküche weil man die
frisch gedruckten blätter aufhängt und
eine werkstatt war es auch tanzen heißt
nein heißt nicht aber staubig und laut
die knechte fluchen der drucker
schimpfte verleger strom ist war lautet
warum kam erasmus hat nicht ausgerechnet
nach basel
er war qualitätsbewusst und wollte einen
drucker mit wunderschönen buchstaben
also zwei buchstaben und proben war auch
die beste wahl
also fragen der drucker aus jener zeit
in gehörte druckereien ja er ist mit
alto manus in venedig einfach spitze es
gibt nichts besseres und rasmus wollte
nur das beste für sie ist es ja so dass
erasmus eine sehr berühmte figur war
konnten denn auch die basler ihre nerven
zwei auch so was wie eine stadt
berühmtheit erasmus hat sich bei der
ankunft einen scherz erlaubt und sich
bei froben angemeldet als freund von
erasmus und diese kleinen scherz wurde
sofort durchschaut ihr wort berühmt
bekannt als er konnte nicht inkognito
reisen und warum hatte sich diesen
scherz und weise bescheiden
ja und auch er war ein lustiger mensch
erfreut humorvolle hat halt versucht mit
seiner berühmtheit spielerisch umzugehen
thomas hofmann hier statt für ihn baten
sie müssen erasmus drauf haben als teil
ihres repertoires verbindet sie auch
persönliches lassen 1000
ich habe vor vielen jahren lob der
torheit gelesen und mich grund gelacht
erasmus ist gut für viele anekdoten und
geschichten zu allem etwas gesagt und er
gehört zur geschichte von basel wie kaum
ein anderer
conti steht da geschrieben ich weiß von
nichts war das so etwas wie ein rasendes
lebensläufe absoluter war unbeugsam in
seiner meinung hat vor nichts angst sagt
höflich aber bestimmt was er meint und
oft mit einem ironischen zwingen im auge
[Musik]
ja wir sind jetzt hier im basler münster
wir stehen vor der grabplatte des
erasmus von rotterdam eigentlich eine
seltsame ehre dass der katholische
priester erasmus schlussendlichen
protestantischen münster begraben werden
sicher eine spezialität eine
besonderheit aber er liegt hier nicht
als katholik sondern als geistes
gegangen als forscher und als freund der
leute die die platte für ihn organisiert
haben und war den eröffnungstag wirklich
immer genau hier schwierige frage ist
gewandert ursprünglich liegt er im hoch
und auch die platte steht
dann wird im neunzehnten jahrhundert bei
umbauten die platte hier hin verschoben
aber das skelett bleibt liegen
später sucht man verzweifelt den echten
erasmus findet ein skelett und stellt
fest dass keine tatspuren von syphilis
einer geschlechtskrankheit das war ein
skandal der junggeselle und pries der
erasmus sollte eigentlich keine tiflis
haben nach einem riesigen gelehrten
streit hat man dann weiter gesucht und
schlussendlich ein skelett gefunden mit
einer medaille in der hand auf der
erasmus drauf stand also das skelett war
identifiziert das erste war der falsche
das zweite der rechte und nun liegt er
endlich wieder hier unter unseren füßen
und dann ist aber dem skelett erasmus
doch noch einmal etwas widerfahren ist
ist ihm ein objektiv auf den schädel ja
das war ganz peinlich man hat natürlich
was man findet in rocky wird
fotografiert man hat ein objektiv auf
seinen schädel fallen lassen
der kopf des geistes giganten wurde
pulverisierte liegt jetzt kopflos hier
der erasmus ist also nicht nur
zeitlebens weit gereist sondern selbst
auf skelett hat ist noch einige
reisestationen gebraucht wenn ihr uns
diesen kommunisten noch einmal vor augen
führen was ist von erasmus in basel
langfristig nachhaltige blieben nur ein
beispiel 100 jahre nach seinem tod wird
eine beschreibung von basel
veröffentlicht von matthäus merian diese
grabinschrift wird in voller länge
abgedruckt und es ist völlig klar wer
nach basel reist muss unter anderem
dieses grab besichtigen es ist eines der
wichtigsten objekte der stadt
vielen dank an so meyer gern geschehen
grüne fonds humanismus war eine
bedeutende epoche doch wie alle epochen
war auch die renaissance irgendwann
vorbei und doch ist vom humanismus
einiges geblieben
das meint zumindest der philosoph
adriano mannino den ich jetzt bei mir
begrüße herzlich willkommen danke für
die einladung
adriano marino warum sollten wir den
humanismus nicht einfach bachab schicken
naja ich glaube unsere zivilisation die
heutige zivilisation beruht zu einem
großteil auf den errungenschaften des
humanismus und der aufklärung und den
zentralen gedanken könnte man vielleicht
so zusammenfassen vernunft orientierung
damit wir das beste aus den menschen
herausholen kann
aber es geht darum das beste aus den
menschen herauszuholen das beste aus dem
denken aus dem denkorgan des menschen
raus zu tun warum diese konzentration
auf die vernunft
ich glaube dass ich meine es gibt wohl
kaum einwände dagegen dass wir das beste
aus uns rausholen sollten hoffe ich
zumindest
und wenn wir uns überlegen was das
konkret bedeutet dann denke ich müssen
wir das definieren unter rückgriff auf
zielerreichung also wenn man alle unsere
ziele erreichen individuen und
gesellschaftlich dann kann man sich eine
welt aus malen in der alle ihre ziele
jederzeit erreichen
ziemlich utopisch natürlich das
vielleicht auch schwer vorstellbar man
denkt sich würde das nicht so langeweile
führen dass aber begrifflich nicht
zulässig weil die vermeidung von
langeweile wäre ja auch ein ziel unserer
seite aber eben dass diese utopie sich
auszumachen es vielleicht schwer
vielleicht ist das auch ein grund
weshalb ist mehr düster bis auf
utopische literatur gibt jedenfalls das
beste aus uns rausholen hat sicher viel
mit zielerreichung zu tun und wenn wir
unsere ziele erreichen wollen dann
brauchen wir ein stimmiges ein
stichhaltiges modell der welt vielleicht
ein reales beispiel wenn mein weltmodell
aktuell besorgen würde das im nebenraum
ein wilder löwe auffahrt der jetzt
gleich auf mich los gelassen wird wenn
das mein welt modell wäre dann würde ich
hier jetzt nicht mehr sitzen sie müssen
vielleicht die sendung abbrechen oder
würden sie dann trotzdem austria und
vielleicht dem computer grundrecht
erst recht vielleicht aber irgendwie
kommen die sparte man sieht wenn man
forschungswelt modell hat dann kann das
ins auge gehen auch gesellschaftlich und
gerade im ethischen bereich jetzt dieses
falsche weltbilder geben sie mir ein
stichwort die giordano bruno stiftung
die bezieht sich auch auf den humanismus
sie selber sind mitglied dieser stiftung
und die giordano-bruno-stiftung wendet
sich gegen alles religiöse sie findet
religion ist unvernunft wird da nicht
ein stück weit eine hexenjagd betrieben
ich glaube nicht
also ich glaube was relativ und
kontrovers es ist die kritik der
fundamentalistischen varianten der
religion
diese varianten wollen viele
errungenschaften des humanismus und der
aufklärung schlicht rückgängig machen
das kontroverse ist ist quasi die eine
militante kritik auch gegenüber
moderateren versionen des religiösen die
mit den haupt errungenschaften der
aufklärung und eine liberale
gesellschaft kompatibel gehen
das scheint mir kontrovers hat aber auch
hier also wenn ich mir also damit haben
sie kein problem
intellektuell habe ich schon ein problem
damit ich habe noch kaum philosophisch
theologische verteidigungen auch
moderator religion gesehen die mich
überzeugt haben also oft weder mit
schwammigen thesen operiert
schwammigkeit auch ein problem für die
vernunft und weiß man nicht einmal wenn
man nicht diskutiert aber ich glaube
durchaus dass sie einen ballabend punkte
angesprochen haben dass atheisten haben
teilweise auch die tendenz sich dann auf
die religionskritik zu versteifen und
unglaublich viel zeit auch noch in die
kritik moderate religion zu investieren
und hier müsste man sich fragen na ja
sollte man jetzt auch aus ethischer
perspektive nicht versuchen sich
vielleicht man kann sich ja auch um die
welt an mut können werden diese zeit
nach wie vor sterben zum beispiel
sondern auszutreiben gleich beim
wiederverkauf der punkt ist wenn sie
sich herr mannino auf den humanismus
beziehen dann muss man jedoch festhalten
dass er raus muss eben dieser große
vordenker der renaissance humanismus ja
selber katholischer priester war und
durchaus versuchte er ein religiöses
leben mit einem vernünftigen leben in
einklang zu bringen ist das kein ideal
für sie naja man muss diese figuren
natürlich in ihrem historischen kontext
interpretieren ja als auch hier haben
wir natürlich ein tief christlich
geprägtes umfeld und wenn jemand da
erste schritte geht richtung
religionskritik richtung historisch
kritische methode in der text exegese
und so weiter richtung religiöse
toleranz und menschenrechte und so
weiter dann ist das eine große leistung
die man auch rückblickend durchaus
feiern darf also mein erasmus hat viele
werke verfasst zum beispiel das lob der
torheit die ja wirklich gleich und
danach erwarten und wichtig unglaublich
wichtige gedanken auf den auf den punkt
bringen ich meine vernunft beruht
eigentlich auf geistige offenheit ja
wenn man geistig nicht offen ist kritik
nicht auch als geschenk sehen kann dann
ist es mit der vernichtung mit
fortschritt nicht weit her
und in diesem werk wendet er auch das
stilmittel der satire der ironie auch
durch selbstironie also er lässt
sozusagen die torheit allegorisch
personifiziert auftreten und die torheit
die lob dann sozusagen die
weltumspannende riesen blödheit also da
kriegt kriegen alle ihr fett weg fürsten
kaufleute natürlich auch die priester
auch der vögel natürlich aber besonders
auch die katholische kirche und weil
eben das ganze satirisch ironisch bricht
kann man ja eigentlich ungeschoren davon
das buch landet dann natürlich trotzdem
auch auf dem index der verbotenen bücher
aber ich glaube dass es unglaublich
wichtig auch diese selbstironie zu
kultivieren um einen offenen geist
motivieren zu können aber sie würden
dabei bleiben wenn ich sie zitieren
darauf diese riesen blödheit der welt
die wie ihre kleineren alle menschen
ungläubig wären ja das würde ich glaube
ich schon so unterschreiben also ganz
klar bezüglich der fundamentalistischen
varianten aber doch aus ich glaube
geistige klarheit und die verminderung
geistige
intellektuelle konfusion scheint mir
wichtig insgesamt und ja ich habe leider
noch keine leider gott das hätte ich das
gesagt noch keine philosophisch
theologische verteidigung der religion
gehört die mich überzeugt hatte jetzt
gibt's ja auch eben die frage was er mit
diesem humanistischen erbe eigentlich
alles anstellen soll und sie herr
mannino sagen wir sollten den humanismus
evolutionär weiter denken das ist das
stichwort der evolutionären humanismus
was genau verstehen sie darunter
genau so revolutionär in einem
dreifachen sind erstens sollte der
humanismus selbst keine geschlossene
ideologie sein sondern ein offenes
denksystem also sollte sich selbst
weiterentwickeln können
im lichte neuer erkenntnisse ich meine
ansonsten wäre ja selbst dogmatisch dann
zweitens wissen wir seit darin dass der
mensch auch ins tierreich gehört also
biologisch sind wir
trockennasenaffen der evolutionsbiologe
richard dawkins pflegt zu sagen
alle wissen dass wir uns oft wie affen
verhalten aber dass wir offen sind ist
etwas was wir uns noch selten wirklich
vergegenwärtigen das wissen wir seit
darwin und das stellt eine prämisse eine
historische prämisse des humanismus des
klassischen humanismus auch etwas in
frage weil traditionell ging man davon
aus dass der mensch als spezies auf
einem metaphysischen sockel steht hat
natürlich auch lohne der krone der
schöpfung natürlich aber auch in
säkularen philosophien gegen man oft von
einer ganz klaren die chemie zwischen
mensch und tier aus und diese dichotomie
wird fraglich
wir sind ja nur tiere das ist dann auch
ethisch eine brüchige rechtfertigung für
unseren umgang mit anderen tieren mit
nicht menschen tieren und drittens denke
ich an stellt sich die frage also wenn
wir uns dann unseren evolutionären
ursprung vergegenwärtigen
ob wir unseren biologische evolution
einen status quo heute ein verlieren
sollten
oder versuchen sollten ihn auch weiter
zu entwickeln wir leben in einem
zeitalter der aufstrebenden
computertechnologien biotechnologien
genetische eingriffe werden möglich neue
technologische eingriffe werden möglich
und da stellt sich die frage sollten wir
womöglich die evolution die evolution
den fortgang
in die eigene hand gehen jedoch gleich
bei diesem dritten punkt also das was
ich vorhin mit herrn rudolf diskutiert
wurde unter dem stichwort humanistische
bildungsideal wollen sie gerne
weitertreiben indem sie sich fragen
können wir nicht statt uns nur zu bilden
uns auch technologisch aufrüsten
dann wären wir bei so nah dran so man
ist ischen idee wir menschen können
eigentlich besser werden wir können
trauen journalisten seien genau
technologische aufrüstung ich meine hier
würde ich sagen ja das tun wir aber seit
jeher also wenn wir ein kind zur schule
schicken und mein erasmus hat darüber
natürlich auch intensiv geschrieben
werden nicht aus menschen geboren
sondern aus menschen erzogen
wenn wir ein kind zur schule schicken
dann natürlich auch mit der
absichtliches kind zu bilden
intelligenter zu machen vielleicht
ethische zu rentieren weitervermittlung
und so weiter aber im grunde also was
wir hier machen jetzt auch
materialistisch gesprochen im rahmen
eines sachen menschenbildes also wir
finden sozusagen schallwellen in das
gehirn des kindes was delayed person hat
sagt und hoffen dann auf positive
veränderungen letztlich auch
neurobiologisch letztlich ist auch eine
neurobiologische vorgang also alle
kultur sprechen die jungen
sicherstellung der schalung bedeutsamen
beschallung unglaublich wichtige
bezahlung aber das ist sicher auch ein
aspekt dessen massive abgeht und im
grunde auch eine neurotechnologie und
nun kann man sich fragen na ja also
angenommen wird könnten sozusagen und
intelligenter machen uns in hessen
epische machen mitfühlende machen indem
wir vielleicht irgendwann der einst mit
computerchips arbeiten oder mit
genetischen veränderungen
zwillingsstudien zum beispiel haben
gezeigt dass das mitgefühl auch eine
genetische grundlage hat die aktuelle
varianz lässt sich etwa zu 50 prozent
auch genetisch erklären
da kann man sich fragen ja was würde
eigentlich dagegen sprechen wenn die
risiken gering genug sind natürlich dass
ich meine frage also eine risikoabwägung
aber ich glaube muss sich auch
vergegenwärtigen dass das nichtstun auch
ein risiko sein kann
also wenn wir nicht mit führenden und
vernünftige werden dann werden aktuell
bestehen der ethische katastrophen ich
hatte die 20.000 kinder erwähnt die nach
wie vor täglich an den folgen der welt
damit stärken wir haben nach wie vor
globales kriegsrisiko und so weiter wenn
wir als spätes viel mit fehlender werden
dann würden diese ethischen risiken dass
ich mir das auch gelungen dass man etwas
im menschlichen gehirn verändern könnte
dass er nicht viel mehr wird aber wir
können ja auch in andere richtungen
denken also nick bostrom einer der ganz
großen vordenker des traums mannis muss
der plädiert zum beispiel dafür
embryonen genetisch zu selektionieren
dient sich beispielsweise der
disposition für intelligenz also die
gucken und sagen welches könnten die
intelligentesten kinder sein und wir
selektionieren die embryonen
entsprechend wenn sie auch so weit gehen
also ich glaube man musste einfach
wirklich eine fundierte
risikoabschätzung hier durchführen
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
eine gesellschaft ich meine hier haben
wir natürlich dass gespenster der
designer babys natürlich im raum stehen
und das müsste man auch müssen vermeiden
dass dinge selektioniert werden die die
wirklich keinen individuellen und
gesellschaftlichen vorurteilen mit sich
bringen also noch nicht nur blauäugige
weiß-blauer gegner und nützt nichts aber
besonders intelligent nutzt also wenn
sie sagen sollen ja gut mal aussuchen
werden
es scheint mir da ist schwierig in einem
liberalen staat hier ein verbot zu
begründen
wenn man die schädigung nicht irgendwo
klar festmachen kann ja also wir haben
das einschlafen prinzip ja jetzt war sie
aus jetzt gehen sie auf die ebene des
verbotes ich wollte gerne früheren
wissen ob sie das eine gute entwicklung
finden ist nur noch im sinne des
humanismus in ihren augen wenn die
risiken gering genug sein dann würde ich
sagen definitiv weil ich mein leben
intelligenzen hersman das machen wir
seit eh und je höhere intelligenz ist
ein vorteil für das individuum und auch
für die gesellschaft ich würde aber dann
aus einem dezidiert ethischen
schwerpunkt legen also mir eigentlich
wichtiger ist ist mehr mitgefühl ich
glaube intelligenz gibt es eigentlich
genug in der welt da draußen
das macht uns aber an
mit gefühl und frankreich genau da
kommen doch alle die
behindertenorganisation zum beispiel
alle die menschen die sagen wir müssen
wieder mit gefühl haben für die kranken
menschen für die schwachen menschen für
behinderte wir müssen aufhören bauer und
alles optimieren zu wollen weil der
mensch ist in erster linie ein abhängige
fräsen ein gebräuchliches wesen und
genau das ist eben auch ganz wesentlich
menschlich ich glaube aus humanistischer
perspektive es ist absolut klar dass
kranke und behinderte menschen unsere
volle unterstützung verdienen und hier
und diese pflanze unserer gesellschaft
viel viel mehr tun aber ich glaube aus
dem humanismus folgt auch dass es eben
die menschen sind die unsere
unterstützung verdienen und nicht die
krankheiten und die behinderung gerade
weil es uns um die menschen geht man
kann sich auch vorstellen dass wir haben
als gedankenexperiment angenommen ein
kind kommt krank oder behindert zur welt
und das gebe eine medizinische pille
also eine einfache behandlung ziemliche
risikofrei die man dem kind quasi sofort
verabreichen könnte dann eine therapie
genau würden wir dann zeugen hatten wir
ethische skrupellos vermutlich nichts
und werden erst gruppe nichts dagegen zu
tun und mit der pzb und einfach
allgemein der sich entwickelnden
biotechnologie haben wir die möglichkeit
sozusagen das bereits vorgeburtlich
durchzuführen was wir nach geburt lich
ohne weiteres natürlich auch chemie und
setzten teufels küche da gibt es viele
argumente dagegen eben zum beispiel dass
christ diskriminierungsverbot dass ich
schon erwähnt habe gehen wir einen
schritt weiter sie haben jetzt den tanz
organismus ein stückweit verteidigt
einen anderen standpunkt den sie erwähnt
haben wenn man den humanismus weiter
treiben möchte ist diese idee mit
schülern dazu werden und generell mehr
zu tun wir menschen sollten mehr für
einen unterton
das haben sie nicht zuletzt auch in
ihrer rolle als präsident der stiftung
für effektiven altruismus eine stiftung
die menschen dazu anhalten will eben
sich mehr einzusetzen
zur linderung des leidens von anderen
menschen einander mehr zu helfen
beispielsweise mehr geld zu spenden für
die armen menschen in dieser welt was
hat das noch mal ganz genau mit
humanismus jetzt zu tun
genau eine
wichtige komponente des humanismus
scheint der antidiskriminierungs
gedanken zu sein was wir wollen nicht
diskriminieren ich meine das war auch
teil des traditionellen leiter welt
modells und der menschenbildes weiße
menschen sind mehr wert als
dunkelhäutiger männer mehr als frauen
homosexuellen bisexuellen mehr als
homosexuelle und menschen in unserer
schritte in unserer nationen mehr als
menschen anderswo also wenn man zum
beispiel hier eine klare nicht
diskriminierungs position einnimmt und
dann den blick weitet dann stellt man
fest es gibt eine milliarde menschen die
pro kopf im schnitt mit weniger als zwei
dollar pro tag leben müssen das bedeutet
extreme armut konstante unterernährung
keine sanitären anlagen und das sind
dann die 20.000 kinder pro tag die an
diesem folgend leicht vermeidbar
wegsterben und auch hier wenn man dann
die vernunft anwendet auch die
wissenschaftliche vernunft und zeigen
dir zeigen aktuelle studien dass man mit
ungefähr 3000 franken wirklich ein leben
retten kann zb in der malaria prävention
und hier ist auch wirklich die vernunft
anwendung wichtig weil die studien
zeigen dass manche hilfswerk mit
demselben spendenbetrag wirklich
buchstäblich hundertmal mehr leben
retten als andere und allein die 3000
franken pro leben das ist ein recht gut
erhärtet das resultat und da müssen wir
uns dann schon fragen also wenn wir hier
in der schweiz im reichsten land
eigentlich das es je gegeben hat
durchschnittlich verdienen dann können
wir nicht jährlich gut 3000 oder mehr
spenden
und wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ist
dass sie im grunde genommen gutes tun
eine frage der vernunft sie betonen
immer wieder die vernünftigkeit genau
eine frage der individuellen
zielerreichung und unsere ziele sind
natürlich emotional vermittelt ja also
hier leben die abwägung wäre dann also
über die jahre hinweg stellt sich heraus
haben wir alle die vielleicht konkurrent
macht dutzende menschenleben zu retten
oder eben nicht und für uns steht für
uns auf dem spiel
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr oder
weniger luxus und die humanistische
abwägung hier scheint eigentlich
glasklar und natürlich sind diese ziele
sind die meisten menschen haben auch
mitfühlende ziele und diese ziele sind
verständlich emotional vermittelt das
ist wichtig aber die vernunft ist eben
auch wichtig um herauszufinden
was sind eben unsere ziele und wie
würden wir diese abwägungen treffen
nicht mein unser mitgefühl ist leider
auch in limitierter dass man sich diese
katastrophe die 20.000 sterbenden kinder
gleich neben uns in unserem heimatland
abspielen würde dann würden wir in der
unmittelbaren emotionale motivation
verspüren
ab jetzt braucht es hat eine größere
abstraktion leistung weil wir erstmals
in der geschichte in einem global
village leben und das können wir
emotional kaum erfassen
viele kritisieren allerdings auch dass
das eine relativ politische haltung sei
william macaskill wäre also ein
vordenker ist des effektiven autismus
sein buch es gerade auf deutsch
erschienen er hat sich zitieren lassen
mit der aussage es ist nicht besonders
vernünftig flüchtlingen beispielsweise
zu helfen sondern viel vernünftiger wäre
es beispielsweise leben zu retten wenn
es jetzt darum geht den opfern der welt
zu helfen und man denkt doch irgendwie
wir müssen doch die regeln verändern
müssten die institutionen gerechter die
stadt nicht einfach geld spende also
dieses zitat möchte ich dann noch sehen
ich kenne macaskill relativ gut und
seine position scheint mir eher die zu
sein das ist gerade bei der
flüchtlingsfrage explizit gesagt hat
dass wir politisch aktiv werden sollten
und uns für offene er viel offener
grenzen einsetzen sollten
er hat auch gesagt dass man natürlich
auch die opferzahlen abwägen muss ich
meine jetzt ist dass die
flüchtlingsproblematik deshalb
besonderes talent und es gibt viel
mediale aufmerksamkeit was natürlich
auch gut und wichtig ist aber es gibt
auch diese hintergrund um katastrophe
ich erwähnt habe die noch viel mehr
opfer haut erzeugt also diese fast eine
milliarde menschen nach wie vor die
peymann internet sind usw und darauf
sollten wir natürlich auch ein
politisches augenmerk richten
und ich glaube das kann wir als
individuen tun aber als individuum
können wir also müssen tanzen empirische
frage was am effektivsten ist individuen
können auch an politischen kampagnen zum
beispiel und politische lobbyarbeit
spenden wir als stiftung haben in der
stadt zürich gerade eine initiative
lanciert das ein prozent des
staatsbudgets man effektive
entwicklungszusammenarbeit fließen soll
und selbstverständlich müssen wir auch
im rahmen einer globalen gerechtigkeit
idee
strukturen schaffen ökonomische
strukturen schafften entsprechend
verändern die gerecht sind alle
ressourcen die wir haben sind immer
knapp darauf gucken wo wollen wir sie
einsetzen
und wenn jetzt noch einmal an erasmus
denken sein plädoyer für alte sprachen
die liebe zur kunst dichtung zum theater
da kann man sich ja sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht realistisch was sie da
erzählen sondern humanistisch wäre es
beispielsweise seine kinder zur
klosterschule zu schicken wo die kinder
noch so richtig eine humanistische
bildung erhalten
sie selber haben keine kinder sie sind
noch sehr jungen sie haben eine große
zahl von studenten die ihre organisation
beitreten geben auch sehr viel spenden
wollen aber vielleicht wenn man ein
bisschen älter wird sieht alles ein
bisschen anders aus und man liegt wieder
diese vielleicht ein stück weit
klassischen bildungsideale
beispielsweise ich glaube das ist auch
okay also ich denke könnten eine breite
bildung ist unglaublich wichtig um halt
eben möglichst akkurat das welt modell
hat auch zu haben und historische fehler
nicht zu wiederholen und so weiter wenn
man die zeiten verändert sich heute wenn
wir heute die chance wollen dann müssen
wir auch informiert seien eben über
entwicklungen im bereich der
computertechnologie der biotechnologie
und so weiter und insofern weil es auch
an die humanistisch dass man nicht zu
berücksichtigen
jetzt kunst und so weiter also andere
werte ich glaube nicht dass eine
effektiv humanistische oder effektiv als
touristische haltung den wörther kunst
bestreiten würde aber ich glaube es ist
schon auch wichtig dass die priorität in
frage zu stellen
eben wenn man sich vorstellt dass wir in
unserem land in unserem eigenen land
diese katastrophe hätten der 20.000
sterbenden kinder jeden einzelnen tag
und jemand sich dann überlegen würde ich
will eine großspende tätigen wohin
sollte jetzt fließen ans opernhaus ans
kunstmuseum oder vielleicht doch an
effektive leid minderung und
lebensrettung und ich glaube man muss
differenzieren zwischen einer ethik für
die normale situation und einer
katastrophe nötig und es scheine relativ
und kontrovers kommunistischer sich das
wenn wir es mit einer katastrophe zu tun
haben dass wir dann wohl schon delight
minderung und leben zeitung priorisieren
sollten
und wenn wir hat unseren blick wirklich
global weiten dann leben wir eine
katastrophensituation sie wirklich recht
haben wenn man noch einmal heraus muss
denkt der so viel zeit und energie
investiert hat um diese bibel zu
übersetzen um diesen griechischen urtext
herauszugeben
man muss sich das einmal vorstellen er
ist ja nicht hingegangen und habe primär
jetzt den armen jener zeit geholfen es
gab viel armut
vielleicht war das ein fehler vielleicht
wenn man wenn man nicht mit
entsprechender kritik konfrontieren
würde wäre dann ein punkt zugestehen
aber ich glaube es hat das durchaus auch
mit ethischen absicht getan wesentlich
als ich meine hat natürlich beobachtet
wie viel konfliktpotenzial in auch ganz
unterschiedlichen interpretationen und
auslegungen der religion liegt und ein
wesentliches anliegen war es eben art
von tests zu gehen zu den keulen die
urtext zugänglicher zu machen auch in
der hoffnung dass man dann vielleicht
einen größeren konsens eine bessere
gemeinsame grundlage hat um dann auch
konflikte zu vermeiden
und was macht für sie ganz persönlich
das leben lebenswert und seinen guten
leben ganz viele dinge also man
zielerreichung eigentlich wäre die meta
antwort also wir haben ganz
unterschiedliche ziele
ich habe persönliche ziele die mit auch
viel mit spaß und lust und genuss
natürlich zu tun haben
dann habe ich ethische ziele dann habe
ich intellektuelle ziele und so weiter
als eine vielzahl von zielen aber wenn
man unter diesen zielen muss ich dann
teilweise ab werk das man sagt immer
ökonomisch gesprochen
opportunitätskosten und wenn ich in mich
gehen und mir wirklich überlegen ja was
ist mir zum beispiel eine
katastrophensituation wichtig dann komme
ich schon zum schluss dass es doch die
ethik ist die mir sehr wichtig ist zumal
ich gar keinen so großen trade offs es
gibt auch wenn man in die glücks
psychologie blick zum beispiel studien
die sagen dass es relativ ist natürlich
auch nicht erstaunlich ist relativ
schwierig sich selbst glück zu kaufen
also geld so auszugeben das man wirklich
glücklicher wird aber ein relativ
einfacher weg das zu tun ist besteht
darin das geld weg zu geben ja also die
glücks psychologie das ist so wird den
sie erwählen genau
ist wenn wir vielleicht noch einmal kurz
zum schluss zum lob der torheit
zurückkommen sie haben selber gesagt
ihnen hat das buch sehr gut gefallen
weil ist voller anleitung zur
selbstironie steckt sie engagieren sich
mit unglaublich viel wer wirkliche
besserung der welt hat noch platz für
selbst die runde
ja ich meine manchmal wenn ich die welt
um mich selbst in der welt um einen hand
und von außen betrachtet dann erscheint
mir als ziemlich absurd und sollte ich
nicht vielleicht nicht gelöst werden und
dann nach ich über mich und ich glaube
das ist so wichtig weil das tier zur
geistige offenheit zur kritikfähigkeit
zur einsicht dass kritiken geschenk ist
und ja ich glaube es drosselt auch dass
extremismus potenzial das in allen nicht
mein mann kann jede idee sozusagen ins
extreme ziehen auch den humanismus auch
den effektiven aus tourismus und ja ich
meine ich muss zugeben ich habe diese
tendenz vielleicht auch manchmal aus
soll über einen ethischen kaum zu stören
wenn ich irgendwann die weite welt
hinaus blicke und und an ihr verzweifeln
aber lob der bescheidenheit zu
beschreiten sogleich zum humanismus
lernen können durchaus genommen ich
danke ihnen sehr adriano man ihnen für
dieses gespräch beginnen nächste woche
setzen wir die debatte um dogmatismus
und religionsfreiheit fort mein kollege
juri steiner trifft den philosophen
carlos fränkl der seinen autismus in
dialog mit gläubigen menschen austestet
um zum überraschenden schluss kommt
glauben und wissen verbindet mehr als
wir denken jetzt gleich gehts tief in
die welt der mythen und ins reich des
teufels wir zeigen ihnen ein filmporträt
über den uhr normaler heinrich download
dessen roten teufel in der
schöllenenschlucht sie sicher kennen
danke für interesse und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]